[Music]
Once
[Music] The
origin of the fire was in
the world of humans, but
an unidentified living creature demon suddenly flew in
, ending the human world.
There were those who continued The
only existence that could stand against the demons
Their women
ran up from the samurai dumplings
[music]
I found only one thing that
didn't waver A dream that someone would laugh at If I had a promise, I
'd get it
Other than just a base  And those who like that world
[Applause]
I'm hiding it because it's more than breaking
through the limit
.
Judging is
crazy [music] I'm going
to thank the incarnation and eat it
Yeah, when
I grow up I'll become a
candidate and take a lot of stones for my brother
This world is crazy
[music] Is it crazy?
Ru
Musashi
, you're as good as ever We're
proud of you.
Can you teach me how to dig
for stones?
Violence and class discrimination
made us peasants go through hell
.
Terrible, worst, no.
Supplies are the only thing that can stand against demons.
I know
[music]
[applause]
reality  It's fun,
Musashi's technique is as big as ever
.  The samurai are still fighting to defeat that demon
[music]
To regain freedom in Hinomoto
Can they win against cool but huge monsters
?
I'm
sure we'll fight together with
our comrades  Let's do what,
you and I will become samurai, then we'll leave town and
exterminate demons together
.  Laughter]
[Music]
Tomorrow is the climbing ceremony.
Let's recite our dreams
Today is the day to say
what is everyone's dreams like this?
It's
finally the climbing ceremony - finally my dreams come true
Let's get scared together Musashi I have a
little business so
what's the business
?  Are you
hungry or not?
I've come to talk to you about
what you
're trying to
say?  I've
been training steadily with this pickaxe while weaving
. For five years, I'm leaving the city with you
.
My ancestors were samurai, and that's why I was discriminated against in the streets, so
before my father died, he
attacked me and told me kind lies
.  Do
n't you give up on your dreams? Don't give up on
your dream
of becoming a samurai
.
[Music] My
dream for the future is
to become Kofu
[Applause]
ーーThat's a
big
deal, don't give up on your dreams
You say the exact opposite in front of me and at school I
can trust you  I
can't do it It's a dream for
you who keep deceiving people around you with your mouth
I don't want to be told what it is You didn't like it Look at me, I
'll prove my seriousness I
want you to live honestly
Musashi
[music]
Look, even the way he laments is garbage  Pick it up,
come on,
don't look at the samurai
[music]
Early autumn hat
Article 9, paragraph 3 A
samurai
must carry a sword for identification Because
samurai are sojourners during the Sengoku period
[music]
Child of supplies
Immortality  Thoughts
[music]
You are different from me
You should become a splendid Kofu
[music]
Huge
My dream of becoming a samurai is
serious Look at me
(laughter)
I don't want you, who keeps deceiving others with your mouth, to tell me it's a dream
.  Hey,
I'm here to defeat the demons
I'll prove my resolve
Please put your luggage in front of the gate and
carry on the purification tree
Now this is the paradise you'll be working in from today
This is the
600 million newcomer  It
seems the time has come for your dreams to come true, even if it's slavery For
the sake of the demons, let's do it before we
die Get off
that
demon,
right?
Even if demons are monsters, that
's the first step towards my dream Musashi in the Kanemaki penal colony
will exterminate the demons
.
Extermination of demons?
[Music]
What am I doing?
You're going to be killed. It's the job
of ugly people to exterminate demons.
I was deceiving
myself because I
was honored by my clothes,
so I didn't want to be left out of the group.
That's what I mean,
my dream came true  My mood is a
dream
It's a dream I learned at school It's a dream of
happiness
Oh my God, my dream is
uncouth
[music]
Kojiro
What is that?
It's
true, you
shouldn't believe me, right
?
I'll prove it to you Musashi, what are you thinking of?
-No way, the prince [music] is amazing Musashi
This
is me I'm not inviting you because I'm afraid of exterminating demons
alone What the hell is this?
[Music]
I've just reached the top of my adventures Who should I be happy
with? I can eat well alone.
He's the greatest guy, the leader of the
demons,
Echizen, as
usual, but
you're the one who's doing the
tricks.  Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Seeing through the air I was reading,
it became air
What am I
doing?
[Music]
What color are you?
Music]
I was saved this time thanks to you.
It's
just that